man that fragile
you'll Clint you need a battery all
right here you go
does this actually work let me see that
I think it's good family might break it
yeah okay we put on the camera now
whoops it slipped brookey more real
battery it works fine it's a rough draft
and we need to revise it it's for 25 and
we are currently writing the script for
the video err changer today we are
shooting a video called early access
matrix why would we figure out the
script last second and shoot it the next
morning that might seem a little rushed
and it is but why I think we're trying
to be consistent finally Clint and
Adrian are working with us in the studio
we have a lot of filmmakers who are
trying to do shorts for the port or
channel and we're like okay you know
what let's let's up our output let's get
more consistent let's try and find a
more regular schedule
the main point though is that we got to
be shooting videos more often I decided
to kick it off by getting the
early access matrix video shot and
filmed after eight years of filmmaking
and doing shorts like this it's a little
easier for you to roll into something
without plan and then still get a video
that turns out Brandon once describes
the way their schedule works so when
we're doing the Freddy W videos the way
we keep on schedule is we picked a date
and time that we're going to come out so
we're weekly Thursday's are like 9:00
a.m. for a long time we picked that day
because we felt like it was open the way
the front page at the time worked was
like we had slots that we wanted to hit
to maximize our exposure we're like
that's when the next video is gonna be
so when it came time to start making it
it's Sunday
we have four days to go through to get
that video done so we have you know
Monday Tuesday Wednesday and then up to
Thursday but we couldn't come up with
anything on Sunday on Monday the
exercise became like the pressure
mounted right it's like now it becomes
than I need opinion in three days it's
gonna wow the audience the people are
enjoy it on Tuesdays we have two days
Wednesday one day and sometimes we get
so far there b.o.b Wednesday evening and
we still wouldn't have an idea by that
point squid 12 hours like the pressures
really certain amount and interesting ly
some of the best videos we ever made
came out of that system like for example
serial killer the lessons that we
learned doing that was try very hard to
come up with something earlier and stay
ahead of it and so put the pressure on
that because we know how bad it was
snowball but by never letting ourselves
slip it kind of treated through that
discipline and helped us the exercise of
ideation think of coming up with ideas
like like a muscle just like anything
else it's like you want a muscle get
stronger you go to the gym you workout
you plan activities to make it
strengthen the muscle if you want to
come up with ideas more efficiently
you're never going to come up with them
unless you're setting aside time it's
like we got a we got to do it and we got
to doing our pressure and it's this
interesting is often like during those
brainstorm sessions we're like I need an
ID I need an idea
yeah the idea would never rarely come
during that but then once you're like
let's take a break and go to lunch at
lunch that's when you come up the idea
or hop in the shower
that's any coach the idea it would never
just happen in a shower if you weren't
already putting in the hours to like try
to come up those ideas outside this is
interesting the ideas would rarely come
during the like actual brainstorming
it's that it cannot around it don't fall
for us our videos are still gonna be
pretty big
we're shooting videos every single week
for at least the next two months
everyone knew this video wasn't totally
ready but I was still like hey I'm still
shooting we're still shooting we're
figuring out right now yes we're
shooting tomorrow morning I would much
rather just shoot and get a video light
that fuse you know to me we have a huge
eight week schedule we're let's set it
on fire let's go all right we are on our
way the sivadier Expo where we are going
to be meeting with Anton of our battery
company
Anton Bowers like one of the old
standbys of battery tech in the film
industry back in the day they made a
solid Valarie that had a mount called
the gold now it's been used for
basically every professional camera
anytime you see like a camera as the
prop in the movie it's usually an Anton
Bauer battery on the back of it they
have new batteries that just launched
today no yesterday they're brand new a
whole bunch of new tech in them and they
make velox we use v-loc batteries for
all of our cameras in our Reds whom use
gold mount for all the lights why do I
do that yeah I like to keep our
batteries a little bit separate so that
we have a set of batteries just
dedicated to our lights the set of
batteries just dedicated to our cameras
I hate wires so that's why I use
batteries for all our lights that's
where they're all led most people don't
know that Anton bar makes v-loc
batteries so now you know Anton bar
makes Duloc batteries anyways let's go
[Music]
we are New York City I just drove down
to New York City guys and there's a
camera car so here is the new battery
just launched yesterday launched
yesterday publicly launched yesterday
with air in stock in all dealers around
in Europe already so you could walk into
you know P and H for example today and
you could get one in V mount if you
wanted to we make the amount
yeah in fact we've been doing it since
2014 we just didn't tell anyone
to meet battery you know it's more
compact than our last generation factory
but at the same time more long-lived and
more powerful it says ninety on the
front but it's actually ninety nine watt
hours so tempts them more for money we
keep it under 100 so it's quite safe
right officer you can put as many of
these in your carry-on as you wish and
percentage on a USB and P tap on there
yeah we put usb on there and we're
finding the people are using it for
charging their cell phone so I can just
have a really fancy cell phone charger
right here yep so this is yours mate
take you have a play cool thank you drop
it man that fragile
sorry
that's a bill to take this just just be
careful with it we'll go home and we'll
plug this into her head we'll see if it
still works all right so what's the
reflector what is a reflector anything
that's reflective it's a silk well it's
a fine fine thing made from a presenta
made from like spiders or something we
go back and forth between using
reflectors and silks and I kind of
wanted to talk about it because we have
our own kind of technique that we've
developed our silks and our reflectors
are about the same size we travel with
them they're supposed to be lightweight
supposed to be a small crew the
technique we use to decide whether we're
gonna use a reflector or a diffuse kind
of comes through necessity because we
only have reflectors and diffusers of
certain sizes they're not huge so when
you have sunlight and you're using a
reflector that means you have two
sources of light and very frequently if
you're using a reflector outside you can
actually just flatten out your lighting
let's say you're backlit by the Sun and
then you bounce it back into someone's
face well suddenly you have light
everywhere there's no more shading
there's no more lighting for that matter
sometimes you kind of need to do that
though we can't use the diffuse and the
wide so we're gonna use a reflector in
the white we're gonna even it out by
shooting the light at an opposite or an
oblique angle to create a little bit of
shading or a little bit of fill and then
when we go in close we can now use our
diffusers to even out the light and get
a nice soft glow stuff on someone's face
I personally like that style it makes it
so when you're in a close-up you're
paying a little more attention to the
person's natural features rather than
the weird lighting and inconsistent
contrast and shading that a poorly
placed Sun is giving you and when you're
in a wide it basically makes it so that
way when you are trying to look at
someone's reaction in a wide shot there
is light hitting it and you're able to
read it still brings little clarity to
the wives and it brings a little beauty
the close-ups there's no real right or
wrong way to use diffuse or reflectors
you know when you're filming in
Minnesota for example winter filmmaking
in Minnesota your lighting is great all
the time because the Sun is always just
a little bit lower on the horizon it's
never straight up since you're a little
farther north of the Equator the sun's
always at a lower angle in winter in
those situations I'm definitely using a
reflector because you have that Sun
always kind of at one of these lower
angles you can start playing with your
light when it's top down though you have
to diffuse it you got to diffuse it or
else people just the faces get all
messed up
inside the battery there's an
accelerometer every time it experiences
a shock of more than 100 G and 100 G
sounds pretty bad but actually that's
only a drop from about two feet onto a
hard floor every time it experiences a
drop like that it records it and when it
actually creates time and date stamp as
well so you can you can see when your
battery was dropped that on a charge or
something you can talk about information
off if the battery is still functional
we'll keep using it they're gonna
experience knocks and bangs during their
life and one thing you don't want to
worry about is your battery failing so
we bought it so it doesn't say
Carmichael if you want to see a trick
still work we're gonna test out and see
if it still works after all that
and little bit of truth
hey you never run for five hours so this
is this like the the super strong kind
of learn to break battery yes yes girls
have already scuffed it up hold on
there's a USB port that's battery I know
I wasn't that nice you in charge of it
without this like 25 times
okay so 14 volt well let's see if it
boots it works I mean the camera is not
fully booted up yeah they can't possibly
be reading it correct there's no way and
possibly be getting a car that's really
cool you were just pressing something is
it a touch yeah there's a touch pen
wait you're still just thrown away with
it get my head around that that's just
so wrong